that uh i'm going to read the uh
chairman's script now you're supposed to
record this or
oh you are recording it says right there
all right
as chair of the house resources
recreation and development committee
i find that due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor as a
result of covet 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
the governor's emergency order number 12
pursuant to executive order
2020 this public body is authorized to
meet electronically
this committee oriented this is a
committee orientation meeting
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am conf
i am confirming that one or
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously during
this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneous
listen and if necessary participate in
this meeting by the zoom
platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made
available to the house in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general
court website the notice of this meeting
for this meeting notice complies with
house rules
and rsa 91.
anyone who has a problem accessing the
meeting should call
2000 excuse me 271
3600 or email
h c s l e g
dot state dot nh
dot u s in the event the public
is unable to access the meeting the
meeting will be adjourned and
rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff that are
me
that are that are on the meeting
assisting us
brad greenland committee researcher
brad introduce yourself
hi everyone i'm brad greenland i'm from
house community services
i'm temporarily the researcher for this
committee um
as returning members will probably know
um
joel anderson was the previous
researcher for this committee
he is um ben's retired and i am
temporarily covering this committee
until we find his replacement
hey brad this little let me finish this
then
i just uh i just let me
let me finish the chairman script uh
please note that all
votes are taken during the meeting shall
be done by roll call vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
uh
roll call attendance when each member
states their present
presence please also state whether there
is
anyone in the room with you during this
meeting
which is required under right to know
law
thank you i apologize brad uh i just was
gonna
just wanted you to wave to the folks or
just let them know anybody out there who
you are
but you will be i'll be be you'll hear
more from brad
later on in the program when we uh
talk about what the committee researcher
does i apologize brad it's
i could like uh yeah this is my first
time
be gentle no problem okay
uh let's see now i'm gonna call i
i for the first and last time we're
gonna call the roll
uh and the
the chair the call i'm going to go down
will
be the the chairman
vice chairman clerk then the
the uh the majority
and the minority members that's go out
is the way they are listed
in the uh in the uh house
the general court website uh first off
uh myself i'm uh chair um andy renzullo
he's here i am here and
there was no and there is no one in the
in the uh
area with me uh i have
michael gunski he is not here he is
attending
another meeting uh and we'll be uh
we'll be checking in later
the clerk is juliette harvey bullia is
she here
apparently not i haven't
uh linda gould
linda gould is here i'm alone
i'm alone thank you
uh james horgan i am here and alone
robert harb i'm here in my office
uh alone but my secretary is in another
room
okay thank you jim creighton
i am here alone okay
uh dustin dodge he's not here
he said he had a a
work conflict robert healy
i'm here in my office and i'm alone
mary mayville i am here and alone
lisa post
i am here and alone thank you
uh now uh suzanne smith
uh suzanne smith i am in my home office
and i am alone
judith spang i'm here and i'm alone
chuck grassy i'm at home and i'm alone
suzanne gottling here alone
bruce cohen i am here and i'm alone
rosemary run i'm here and alone
erica connors i'm in my home office and
i have
one child in here with me right now okay
suzanne vale
thought i saw suzanne she was here
unmute suzanne
she's muted oh you're muted uh
suzanne you're
you're still muted is that she's not
showing us being muted so i don't know
what the problem is she must be having a
mic
problem grabbed are you unmuted i mean
you may need to just log out of the
meeting log back in sometimes
um there we go there she is
can you hear me now yes my favorite
words
sorry about that um i tried i know you
can hit all
alt a or you can toggle but anyway
um i'm here and i'm alone in my office
okay thank you just hold your space bar
too and that'll
unmute your mic
normally that works but today
okay i'm gonna leave
okay i'm gonna continue uh
eamon kelly i am here and alone and
great pronunciation
is it yeah no you did it right thank you
all right don't worry i'll screw it up
eventually
it's okay but with a name like renzullo
i'm sorry
it just it happens you should hear what
people kill my name
uh melbourne moran i'm here i'm alone in
my office but my wife and child are in
the office next to me
okay and that is that's
and of course there is uh
there's brad uh but he's not
i don't believe he's a part of well i
know he's not part of he's
he is staff but he's not part of the uh
role he's not a voting member the role
so roll call
all right mr chairman yes
i can't see uh brad's face
uh brad did you kill your face
i can turn my camera on one moment
great thank you brad
all right okay now
uh i'll start with the
uh part of the out of the committee
handbook
or the chairs the chairman's the house
chairman's handbook
they have a thing called the committee
organization day so
um this is this is probably all old hat
for those those of us who've been here
at least one term
but buff so most of what we're going to
be doing is
uh to bring the uh uh
try to get the new folks uh up to speed
but
but one of the the first thing we're
going to do is we're going to introduce
ourselves
and i'm again i'm going to go by the by
the list and uh
who we are what we do what's where do we
uh
uh what how long we've served uh
what uh well what pounds we represent
also anything you want to share with the
with
the with the others uh and this is a lot
easier done
believe me it's much easier done when
we're when we're in
live session we're just a group chatting
this is kind of stilted way of doing it
but the only way we could have right now
my name is andy renzolo it's uh
r-e-n-z-u-l-l-o i'm the chair i've been
i've been doing this
state house business for uh this is my
eighth term
uh the i've chaired this committee
before
10 years ago
i'm representing the town of hudson and
the town of pelham
we have a large district it has 11
members in it
largest one in the state it's a
it's two fairly two uh mediums one
medium size and one large size town
how it got that way was that's that's
another story
uh the you know i
uh i've now lived in
lived in new hampshire now maybe 40
something
years so
it's you know that's just about it you
know what what do i
what do i like to do well you see behind
me i have a lot of
a lot of uh glassware and stuff on my
i like old things because i'm old so uh
that's uh you know and uh my house is
like a museum
so but anyway that's uh what i do now
and that's uh that's who i am and uh
that's i'll pass it on to the next
person
can't be chairman guns vice chairman
gunski he's not here at the moment
i don't know did the juliet harvey bola
bolia sign in i guess she
hasn't uh so she
she's not here also uh linda
uh here's linda gould
uh representative gould could you tell
us the committee
more about yourself sure i'm
representative linda gould i'm from
bedford new hampshire which is near
manchester new hampshire
and i'm a new hampshire native and
i enjoy bicycling and outdoor activities
and that's one thing that attracted me
to this particular committee
i'm in my fourth term i have five
children that are grown up
and uh i don't know anything else
oh i do want to say something andy
green a little bit because the upper
part of your face we can't see
the what the upper part of your face we
can't see
that's better no should it better go the
other way then
okay okay thank you i don't know that
because i
can't see myself that's so i
uh yeah that's thank you for telling me
that
uh james horgan
hi i'm good morgan not to be confused
with representative horrigan
this is a common occurrence uh i'm one
of two representatives at cover
farmington
uh just above rochester below middleton
if you're familiar with the area
uh i've been in farmington for uh since
uh retired from the navy uh and uh
been assisting the community since 93
this is my third term as a state rep
[Music]
and nothing exciting to tell you about
okay that's it all right robert harb
bob yes thank you uh good morning
my name is bob harb i represent plaistow
in atkinson new hampshire way down in
the
south near the near the mass border i
live in plaistow
i'm the place downtown moderator i'm the
timberland school district moderator
i'm an attorney in focusing on real
estate and estate planning by profession
my hobbies and other things i do which
drew me to this committee was i'm an
equestrian so the recreation
brought me in and i am
also a professional karate instructor
and that's enough i think thank you
uh jim creighton
i'm i'm jim crayton i'm from uh district
38 in hillsborough
cover 10 different towns all the way
from uh
greenville on the south up to windsor in
the north
a retired army colonel and i got two
kids
uh and i run two businesses a uh
an outdoor wilderness uh guide company
and
leadership and security consultancy i'm
glad to be here on my first time and
looking forward to working with you all
thanks okay thank you
uh dustin dodge is not here
uh robert healy can you
tell us about yourself hi andy thanks
um i'm uh bob healey from merrimack with
uh
two other merrimack people on this uh
committee
um i've come to merrimack i came to
merrimack from 2008
after being born in france and uh moving
through massachusetts and then through
connecticut um
it's my first term and um
yeah the only other thing is uh you know
the things i like doing outside
is playing golf
okay thank you bob
mary mayville
i already have so many things in common
with a lot of you
so i represent merrimack with rosemary
and bob kealy
um i too am retired from the military
air force lieutenant colonel
um i have a doctorate in nursing
practice and i am uh actively teaching
at northeastern university down in
boston and like
bob i'm an equestrian as well so that's
what drew me to this committee as well
as being outside
and um you know really protecting our
natural resources so
i appreciate meeting everyone and this
is my first term
okay thank you uh lisa post
i'm lisa post can you hear me yeah
okay good i i have the ears on and so i
can't hear myself
um i am um
[Music]
uh from lineboro i cover hillsboro
district 4 which is
wilton and blind borough greenville
and francis town and i also ran with jim
creighton
as he is part of our four um
towns and i look forward to working with
everyone here
my husband and i moved here as empty
nesters
in 2014
but we now have my son and his wife
living with us so that's
quite exciting for us we're all outdoor
people
um we love to hike kayak boat
um you know just discover all the
wonderful things about new hampshire
and i'm super excited to be on this
committee
one of the things i did run on was you
know
protecting our parks and our waters and
our resources so
i look forward to working with everyone
i do have three grown
sons and now luckily have
three daughters along with that so i'm
very excited
to have some girls and shop with them
and hike and ski with them so um
i i look forward to working with
everyone and um
being a newbie uh i hope to um
uh get all your advice and and uh
um suggestions from everyone that's been
on here before
um i look forward to working with
everyone thank you
thank you lisa uh next is
uh the the
ranking democrat member uh suzanne smith
uh just so folks know the new folks know
that uh
she was chair and i was i was the
ranking republican and now we've
changed places and i guess payback
is going to be yeah for what
oh my i don't know i never did anything
wrong
so i said
i meant that payback to me not for me
not for two you anyway okay
all right it came out wrong sorry that's
the problem with these with doing this
with uh
doing this with zoom you can't you don't
see personalities you don't there's no
banter
and under normal circumstances this who
i am and who that this talking
would be a kind of a little bit of a
back and forth a bit uh just to get
you know break the the ice you can't
break the ice on
on a wire so let's watch us just you
want banter
wait a minute he'll give you a banner
hey it's my turn
suzanne okay um i'm suzanne smith
um i represent the towns of plymouth
hebron and holderness in the middle of
the state
it covers squam lake and newfound lake
so i'm a
fitting addition to this committee which
this will be my fifth term
on resources and this will be my seventh
term in the new hampshire house
i'm also co-chair of the hebron
conservation commission
and uh i was interested to hear lisa
saying she's
a birder because i'm inverter also i
also like to kayak hike
uh and i do i'm in a wildlife tracking
group
and this has been a good year for that
and i really look forward to working
with everyone we've got some interesting
bills
coming up some old favorites and some
new ones so it should be fun this year
so
look forward to working with all of you
thank you i think we can
can thank chuck grassy for the old
favorites
he's bringing one back uh next is
uh judith spang
how about chuck he's our next in line in
the democratic line
i'm just going by i think this is done
by the
i think they do the the seniority
how long you've been in the house yeah
as you can probably tell i'm a past
chair also and i think andy was the
ranking republican when i was
chair i've been in for
22 years all but two of them were
on this committee i've worked on
river issues at the local state and even
federal level taking bills to congress
i live in durham and there's very
few outdoor activities that i haven't
done which is why i'm going through my
second
second year with a broken leg um
first hit skiing and now it's boating um
i'm primarily interested in
water issues um but
um maybe surface water issues
not necessarily the pfas and all of
those
um but i'm interested in other things
relating to
the the health of our rivers and lakes
and also living in
durham i'm probably the most interested
in coastal issues of anybody on the
committee
i'm also very um have been very involved
with land conservation
and um i'm concerned about our lack of
stewardship
of our of our habitats and our land
chuck and i have put in a bill to um
to protect our wetlands um nine times
um i'm going to give it a rest this time
and let
chuck take over with the prime wetlands
um so those are my
interests and i'm happy to work with
anybody who
shares any of those interests in
land use land conservation and
land and water protection
thank you judith uh and it's
chuck grassy hey i'm chuck grassy from
rochester
this will be my eighth term i served
five terms way back my first term
actually was back in 1975
where i served five terms and then took
a long break which my wife was here for
10 years serving on children and family
law but back in the 70s i was a
member of the science technology
committee this will be my third term on
this committee
and i've been a i was a town planner
and in the planning field for about 20
years serving in the towns of
alton raymond and stratham i was
involved with the shoreline protection
ordinances and regulations for the state
and have been involved in wetlands and
geospatial mapping
for most of my time as a as a town
planner
uh so i i bring that experience to
working with towns i was also on the
city council here
for almost 30 years and i think that'd
be fun
and uh suzanne you're taking a phone
call and your mic is on
there thank you and served on the
planning board here in rochester for a
number of years as well so
i have a lot of uh knowledge and
experience in the planning field
and environmental services
okay and the next
is guess who
suzanne suzanne gotling zero
can't hear you suzanne
sorry andy my phone just rang so i was
made sure i was muted
um can you hear me now yeah we can hear
you know
okay i'm sue gottling i live in sunapee
uh i represent sullivan county district
two
which is sulliv sunapee and croydon
i'm serving in my sixth term i've always
been
on resources committee and uh
one session i did double duty on ways
and means which was
an interesting trek from the second to
the third floor
uh i also am in my fourth term
as a member of the centipede select
board
i've lived in new hampshire 25 years and
i live on
lake avenue so i have quite an interest
in the health
of our lakes
i serve on the lake sunapee protective
association
watershed committee and at the
base of our lake of course we have the
uh
mount sunapee ski area which in the past
has been a frequent source of
discussion shall we say so
hi everybody and be nice to get to know
the new
folks although there are a lot there
that i already know
okay thanks thank you sue um
bruce cohen representative bruce cohen
hello
i uh represent nashua's ward one
this is my second term on this committee
i'm very happy last year i was very
proud
of the bipartisan work we did to address
issues around pfas
and arsenic in water i consider myself
an environmentalist
i'm very sensitive to issues around that
i'm looking forward to whatever comes
our way this year
i also want to take this time to uh
thank the chairperson for agreeing
to allow those of us with health
concerns to participate
fully via zoom so thank you for that i
do appreciate that
and i'm looking forward to working with
all of you next two years
okay anything else thank you
okay thank you bruce uh the next
is rosemary run rose hi everybody
thank you andy mr chairman um
i'm rosemary wrong i live in merrimack
along with with bob
and mary mayville i've actually lived in
new hampshire
for since 1973 graduated from nashua
high unh
my first career was as a research
analytical chemist and then i moved into
public affairs
for the dow chemical company and i
retired from there in 2009
i have three grown children two
grandsons
which is a lot of fun um i
in my second term uh my first term i was
on resources i served as clerk
and uh i joined because of the pfas
issues facing
uh merrimack i serve as chair of the
pfas commission which was a result of hb
737 a couple years ago and i know bob is
on that commission as well
can you hold up for a second i'm hearing
uh
i'm getting some feedback or some uh
somebody's got something going
years ago i don't think i do no no i
know
oh okay sounds like a television set in
the background yeah who has the tv going
look in here you know everybody give me
everybody hear what i'm hearing
there's somebody having a conversation
in the background somewhere
yeah he's not unmuted
yep let me see my husband's in the next
room let me see if he can
it might be him yeah he might be talking
on the phone
hold on a second i'll yell at him all
right
that is yeah it is
it is her cause she just muted herself
yeah i told him to be quiet
yeah he's on the phone with somebody um
but i saw
i i i'm you know active on pfas issues
um as far as hobbies i'm a part-time
resident
of the town of moultonborough and i'm
active in the lake kanasaka watershed
association so
water quality surface water watersheds
are
really important to me and as far as
hobbies
um you know anything outside in the
summer around the lake hiking kayaking
all that
i like to downhill ski but i haven't
done that in a couple years
and i like to do bead weaving i make i
make beaded jewelry in particular so
that that's a nice hobby of mine and
sewing and crafts i like to do thanks
okay thank you thank you rose
um erica connors hi i'm erica connors
this is my third term in new hampshire
house i previously served on fish and
game
and children and family law last term i
was the clerk on that committee
i was just looking for a little bit of a
change this time around
prior to being the new hampshire house i
served for six years on the manchester
city school board
i have three school age kids they are 12
15 and 17. so we're in the midst of
college process
stuff i take a little different
perspective for this committee i own a
summer
day camp for children so we are on a
lake
here and we are a ski race family so
we're in the mountains all the time and
we do lots of hiking and boating and all
kinds of outdoor activities
okay thank you erica uh
suzanne vale
oh she's still
nope down here yeah
she doesn't look muted she might now
she's muted no
she must have a mic problem or something
because
i don't know what her
no still can't hear
sometimes my headset does that if you if
you check the little carrot a little
tiny arrow next to the microphone you
can select a different microphone
sometimes mine
switches automatically to the wrong one
i don't know i can't hear you suzanne
i'm here do we have a chat function
where someone could
um send her a no i think she can hear us
because she keeps as we say that she
stops talking yeah
so if she goes on her audio and
if she's are you wearing a headset i
don't think she is
yeah no but now i see that my box is
green
right in here yeah we got you now all
right let's try to get through this i
think i'm having a problem with my
keyboard and i just need to reboot but i
don't want to do that right now
um good morning and thank you um
suzanne vale and i live in nashville
ward three
um going into my third term my first was
municipal my second was transportation
and here i am now um looking forward to
working on some things that
i'm hearing others are also looking
forward to
um i'm an outdoor person i've lived in
new hampshire all my life i was born in
nashua i'm
a fourth generation national and um
always had a fascination with our public
lands and the recreation
and things that we could do growing up
without having a lot of money on our
state
um properties and using the white
mountains and
climbing i now have three grown children
who are all also
outdoor people and um
and i guess for in the interest of time
i'll wrap it up with that
thank you thank you suzanne uh
eamon kelly i am eamon kelly
i represent uh the city of berlin i'm
one of three reps from up here
um this is my first term i am uh
my family owns a sawmill up here in
berlin so i've been involved with the
woods my whole life
i'm not involved with that side of the
business but
i'm an outdoors person just like a lot
of people here grew up skiing
way up here in berlin obviously there's
plenty of places to go
yeah i'm looking forward to meeting you
and working with you
thank you very much uh this seems like
you're the only one the
only person north of the notch who's on
the committee
uh melbourne moran
hi um my name is melbourne i'm uh um
representing nashville ward seven um
i live here in nashville with my wife
and three children i
range from four months to five years
i'm a psychotherapist licensed here in
new hampshire massachusetts
i'm from lowell massachusetts i moved
here to new hampshire with my wife who's
a nashua
and new hampshire native uh i primary i
own my own
um mental health and forensic service
agency uh that has offices in new
hampshire massachusetts i primarily work
with
uh suicidal patients uh patients that
are
severe and persistently mentally ill and
i also am an expert uh to the point
where i
testify for people's con competencies
and criminal matters
uh in the state of massachusetts and um
i'm not a recreation person
at all i'm willing to learn about
what's going on in this committee but uh
i'm not an outdoors
person in any any way shape or form i'd
be lying if i said i
i was
okay thank you thank you uh i
i was looking around i see uh uh juliet
uh harvey bolia
is uh uh is here
as juliet
let's see i can't hear you
okay okay hey everyone uh nice to meet
you all
i guess there's a lot of skiers in the
bunch um i recognize suzanne smith uh
from
the plymouth area that's i'm working
today at the town of plymouth i'm
working in the planning department uh so
this is my first
term and um
so i don't really have too much to say
but looking forward to meeting everyone
okay is there anybody that i missed
okay that that's fine that's it okay
we've all introduced each other
unfortunately it's not the
uh uh hi
how are you how we you know then it
isn't the chatting that you normally
see at this kind of introduction usually
there's a little bit of crosstalk
and it's it's it's allow i would
i would normally allow it simply because
it's about the best way to get to know
folks
but we'll all get to know each other
pretty pretty well maybe too well over
the next
uh next two years so
uh now following my my script by the way
is there any questions or anything like
that
is there anybody have any comments uh
you know i don't have a i haven't seen
anybody raise their hand and of course i
don't
uh if anybody does raise their hand
please uh
and i don't don't call on you maybe i
you know this is my first time
fooling around with these uh with this
this little computer screen so
mr chair bear with me yes we also have
a few guests in the uh
who are listening in most and most of
them are people who usually will
would be sitting in the audience uh if
we were
having this live so just wanted to
all right they're all here we got jason
stock jason smith jodie grimbles gary
abbott
matt leahy michelle davis
bob johnson robert johnson and zach
sheehan from the democratic office
it's listed they're listed under
attendees attendees i see
i see eight of them but i can't uh yeah
yeah okay
okay that's that i just called it up
okay
uh i don't
say i don't know if we want to
take the time if you'd like to um
speak um i can allow them to talk uh if
anybody would like to
in the audience uh yeah just just for
you know just that even as just to say
hi in uh
a sentence or two what you've done so
especially for
uh the new folks who are new to the
committee
who uh just say we uh maybe just say who
you are and what uh
you know how you how you help how you
interact with the committee
uh if you could do that i guess uh
joe uh jodi you and uh
okay uh
gremlins for strategic solutions uh
do i have something to say yep
uh can you can you speak is it
hi mr chairman can you hear me yup can
hear you
well um thank you for the opportunity i
wasn't expecting it but i appreciate it
um i'll follow up with an email to the
committee um
as a whole my name is jody grimbalis i'm
a lobbyist here in concord
you'll see me before your committee we
represent the marine industry
so boating the local marinas some of the
manufacturers and voting enthusiasts
we also represent the new hampshire
snowmobile association
so um anything usually snowmobile
related ohrv related we tend to
to work with your committee on um my
colleague his name is adam schmidt
and again i think what i'll do is i'll
send an email to all of you with our
backgrounds and the clients that we
represent
and we look forward to working with you
all thank you for the time
thank you that would be good uh jason
smith
good morning can you hear me yeah my
name is jason smith i work at the new
hampshire fish and game department
i'm currently the chief of the inland
fisheries division
i periodically come before the committee
uh for various bills
so i'm just here listening in and
introduce myself but thank you
jason stock
good morning jason stock i'm the
executive director of the new hampshire
timberland owners association
we represent uh private not
private landowners as well as the
state's forest products industry
you'll hear from us on issues relative
to
forestry forest management wildlife
wildlife issues
also management of state
state lands state of new hampshire has a
pretty pretty robust forest
forest management program and so we we
have an interest in that also
thank you for the chance to speak and i
look forward to the day when we can all
meet
face to face
thank you uh richard parsons
hi i'm rich parsons i just wanted to
introduce myself
we represent the new hampshire off
highway vehicle association at ryp grand
strategies
we also will likely come before you in
some instances for the new hampshire
wildlife federation
and perhaps even eversource at times but
really the majority of stuff with the
atv folks
thank you thank you matt leahy
matt hi this is matt leahy
can you hear me yep hi this is matt
leahy i'm the public policy manager
for the society for the protection of
new hampshire forests
we are a statewide land trust
and our concerns and interests mostly
deal with conservation and forestry
issues thank you very much
okay i seen owen uh else's
anybody else wanting to say
anything michelle davis new hampshire
lakes
hi everyone good morning my name is
michelle davis i'm the advocacy program
coordinator
at new hampshire lakes i'm new to the
position
and to new hampshire as a whole um
so i'm excited to be here and thanks for
giving me the time
new hampshire lakes um works for clean
and healthy lakes
um so you'll be hearing from me about
um issues related to you know water
quality
and aquatic invasive species etc
okay and anyone else from the audience
if not uh okay i'll uh
you know close uh close the close the uh
uh audience uh participation
okay so i can cancel that all right
i have a question andy how do how do we
put up a sign to chat
i don't see a chat signing uh there is
no
chair is no chatting uh i don't believe
uh in uh that we're not set up for that
i don't believe
uh is that is that true brad uh
to speak to that oh that's correct um we
have the chat to say old due to the um
due to right to know concerns
okay does that answer your question
linda and representative gould
sorry you know again it's uh you should
ignore but part of what uh you we have
to learn and i have to still have to
learn it
that you should especially what you're
in session you use the term
you know you use the the representative
uh
you know representative gould not linda
and i apologize
but uh you know that's that's part of
our system of
uh if you're if you're very if you're
for nice and formal then you're not you
you the
things go better things go well uh
so it's you know it's
part of the tradition uh
okay beyond that anything else well i
can go into the next part of the
my what i'm supposed to do uh start time
and notice of absence all right
uh normally we if this were the the
regular
regular world we would be starting at uh
we would be we would be starting at 10
o'clock uh
now what's going to what is going to be
happening is we will be
going to this now special
uh you know will be special
uh rather special rules
for because there'll be hybrid
situations that we have
the way we will be laid out as a
committee
and how we will conduct the meetings uh
we'll have
we will have to we'll be required
to use make maximum use
of the the uh
the these time and the space allotted
so the starting time will be nine
o'clock
and it will end probably
closer to five o'clock than it normally
would
be somewhere around 3 30 4 o'clock but
no we got
we're good the requirements is to pack
as much in
as possible uh the
the way we will be meeting uh
and we can probably talk more about this
later is that we will be
we will be meeting uh
in a hybrid situation the hybrid
situation will be
uh people will be either on
zoom or uh or will be in
in the in the the come in
uh concord in a in a double committee
room
it will be laid out such that
the the double committee room will have
enough
space so that we can socially distance
and wear masks
and but there was also the allowance for
those who wish to
meet in uh meet on a meet
by zoom to also participate
so uh the
these uh all the the big issue and big
issue for me
and i'm i'm sad to say i
do not have any information on exactly
what day we are meeting they
uh they will be i
hopefully they they're talking about
that right now at the meeting that is
going on
of the chairs and vice chairs that that
was
scheduled to go there's a schedule right
on top of this meeting
so the vice chair is attending that
meeting
uh and it is all
it is also a zoom meeting so he's at the
e but he is attending that meeting
to find out what changes or what
variations have occurred
because as to how we
we meet the biggest thing is we're
going to be meeting one uh we are going
to be meeting one of
our our time will be one of the five
days they're going to make
maximum usage of time because they're
going to
only allow uh two meeting
uh two two committee hearings per floor
so that means and that we only have the
the third floor
and the second floor so those
those uh thing those meetings will occur
will be over a f uh over a five day
period
i they will be this committee will be
assigned
a a time slot
uh and it will be a the there will be it
will be a specific day that we will be
meeting
on uh if i if
and we it will but they i have no choice
of
what the meeting day is that'll be that
is that
that is the uh what the speaker will be
making that choice uh and i think a lot
of it has to do with
the amount of uh
of bills we have and uh
i will have to negotiate the time that i
think i need
to be able to meet the
the time they meet the time out for
for these bills um
so that's hopefully and i'm hoping that
uh
representative gunski who is attending
this meeting
instead of being here basically he's
attending on my
request that to get the up the latest
up-to-date
information and he will report back
uh to this uh this group uh
once that meeting is over he'll he'll
tune right in
i see uh rep lisa
they see you have a question um i just
had a question about the chat function
will that be if we're going to be doing
a zoom meeting
are we going to have the chat function
for people to use
that are in the zoom meeting is this
just for today
uh brad can you help me with that
sure so um to the best of my knowledge
we will not be
um enabling the chat function um
for future means as well we um again for
due to right to know all concerns uh we
have that disabled
yeah uh i yeah this is as a public
meeting
uh the chat the chat
isn't viewable by by the public
so that uh is so that that
that would be by we would be violating
the right to know law
so you could have you can do the chat
thing around
caucuses but uh because those are not
public meetings and the
public has doesn't have a right to see
what goes on in the caucus but
uh this this uh this meeting is not
because it is
bipartisan and can i
um can i also ask if um that we have the
ability
to record from our own computers
is that the same of people who are on as
attendees
uh brad
as far as i would because if you ask me
uh uh personally i think that anybody
the meeting is recordable
as far as i'm concerned because it is a
public meeting and public meetings
uh recording in a public meeting is
allowed
especially the governmental meeting
i'm not i'm not sure um the function of
the attendees if they're able to record
but we are also putting it onto youtube
um so it would be available for the
public for
the future as well okay okay thank you
brad
uh any other questions
not i'll
take your hand down
andy yeah i have a question are you
talking about
uh committee hearings where people
can't talk in i mean
how are people going to testify no no
i'm only talking about
the chat function see there's a chat
function here that would allow
that is disabled because the chat
function
uh allows would allow reps to talk
outside of the in committee while in
committee
would allow reps to communicate
uh without uh outside of the view of the
public
oh okay okay i mean if we uh
yeah i realized that in
the uh normal
under under normal circumstances i mean
one rep can lean over and say something
of course which they'll rule them out of
order
uh but but the
chat is you know chat function allows a
conversation that can't be viewed and
that
that would that would get us into
trouble so
any other questions so i'll go on okay
uh notice of absence
you've got to let uh people know that
you're not going to show up
uh there's call the uh uh
yeah you can you can call me you can uh
you can uh uh or you think
you better best always to call the uh
uh the the office uh
the uh call heather heather ebbs
uh she will be uh able to
record there or should take it down and
let and let us know
that you're not that you won't be
becoming
uh it's not a critical thing that you
you if you don't show up but you well
it's a critical thing that i don't know
that you're not showing
uh showing up uh what's uh
but what's cred uh but uh
this is is being letting people letting
uh
people know yeah especially if we're in
a going to be in executive sessions
at all is very crucial to your
to both uh suzanne
smith and myself representative smith
because
that especially if there's a if if their
votes
we we need to know that you're going to
be there because
there is uh if you're not going to be
there
and you there are you can be
uh temporarily replaced for that vote
and if that is necessary uh if we feel
as as the partisan leaders of our
of our parties we'll we'll we need to
time to know that we can
we can get somebody in to vote in your
stead
um i don't know suzanne you want to make
any comments about that
representative smith no
good stuff all right uh
the yeah i am trying to talk
i just had my mute on uh it's heather
goalie not
heather ebbs she got married remember
oh yeah so if you get you'll get your
calendar notices from heather goalie
okay i'm sorry i'll have to apologize to
her but you know i got a big
see see this is my list of apologies i
have to read
a whole bunch of i gotta apologize to a
lot of people
but then again maybe uh you know you'll
never
maybe they'll forget so
[Music]
but i'm not don't worry don't worry
chuck i'm never gonna apologize to you
but anyway okay let's get back to
um the uh
okay that's about the notice of absence
a
single single email account used in life
for legislative business
yeah i don't know most of you should
have gotten a letter
email from the clerk
that from paul smith
concerning use of a preferred email uh
especially this is usual this is
basically aimed at the new folks
who have come in i mean they put down
their email uh
and the but
what's ending up there's a there's also
a legislative
uh email that you've been given you know
and your body not even know that and uh
you have to choose and make certain that
the
the the what email you want to have
all your information from the
legislature
go to so if you haven't got this
have you got this this email from paul
smith says use the preferred email
basically it says as members you have
the right to utilize the legislative
email system with your name
or utilize a personal email system the
legislative email system is the one with
your name
plus at leg.state.nh.us
we ask that you choose one email for
all legislative use as trying to jiggle
between which address you want posted on
on the website versus which one you want
committee researchers or assistants to
send you
information is incredibly time consuming
so he's asking for one
and that one email so
i know in having to get in contact
with some folks uh a lot of a lot of
it took me a while to get it get through
to uh
just to some folks um
any questions on that
okay dress and decorum
uh dress is pretty
you know it's a bit old it's been open
but it should be
you know business business casual
uh or bit or at least not well
she should i'll say i'll speak for the
men
you should uh where you should wear a
jacket
remember you're in front of the public
uh
and uh uh
the uh you're you're you're so that's
you know you're where you're you are
you're you're represent you're a
representative you're representing the
state
so uh uh if if if you're on
uh if it's gonna if you're on zoom
i think i don't think like i'm not
wearing a tie
uh tai is not necessarily
uh uh necessary but
uh you know no t-shirts please or
anything like that that's
uh uh suzanne i don't know if you want
to speak to
the what the what's best i'm not
what's what's best for best dressing for
is
for women
um as andy said business casual
which means you know neat and
presentable
clean clothes uh
nice shirts things you want wouldn't
want to be
have your remember all of these are
public so even if you're on zoom
someone could be photographing it and
putting it on facebook or on the tv news
so
you want to look presentable and if it's
zoom
obviously you don't have to wear proper
shoes but
um you know from the waist up you
definitely want to look
fairly presentable
thank you when we're meeting in person i
would say no jeans
but nice slacks are always appropriate
any any questions or comments on that
thank you all right food co uh
food coffee and lunch breaks all right
we do have lunch breaks but sometimes we
will work through them
the general rule is that we
have a we will have a lunch break
built into the into the schedule
the the general rule is no
food during public hearings uh
there's uh there should be
uh uh there's you allow
water you know you keep water if
if you want soda or coffee just
i just keep it under the table just
don't just don't
just don't kick the cup over uh you know
it's kind of that type of thing i mean
i'm i'm
fairly loose about that but uh you
realize
uh you know having a a coke
sitting right in front of you uh does
doesn't doesn't look good
especially if it's being uh you know
broadcast so just uh uh
but a bottle of water is fine and if you
know if you
if you feel like me you'll need a candy
every now and then
sneak one but that's so that's not a not
an issue
but it's just sometimes
people will push push the issue one of
the
also is there will be times when we will
not
take a lunch break but we will have we
will
will allow the hearings to continue
where i have would have peop people go
out
and bring back their lunch and eat it at
the at the desk
that's fine if i allow it you know and
that's
uh that's an um a uh um that's in a
situation that's a unique situation but
you will see that
you might see that and in this issue
the way it is now you may see it more uh
use of electronic devices
it's it's uh
dull your phone you know you put it on
vibrate or better yet shut it off
uh it's you know i think if it goes off
once you you'll be very embarrassed and
usually it doesn't happen again until
the next time so
just uh just be aware that you have a
phone
if you're new you're expecting a call
put it on but
uh put it on uh vibrate so you don't uh
interrupt the uh
what's up interrupt the proceedings any
questions on that
then okay next thing in my list is the
drawer
you will be assigned
a drawer for yours for your stuff it's a
large
uh drawer that is for anyone who's uh
had
uh you know been in a drafting area
where they put that their large drawers
that
uh wide wide but now uh
but uh not very deep it's where that
that
they put in uh
large drawings or schematics things like
that
it's that kind of drawer there's a whole
there are several
stacks of them everybody will be
assigned one it will have a key
so you can leave stuff in it uh you can
it has a reasonable amount of
storage space there you do not have a
desk
the only one that has a desk
is the chair i
in the previous tour as a as the chair
uh i used the desk this to basically sit
in it has a computer
and i i didn't but i did not store much
in it
other chairs dual use a lot use it a lot
it's just
my i work out of a briefcase
but uh again you will have a drawer you
have a lock and key
i do not believe they are under this
in the under this pen with the pandemic
going on and in the uni
in the uh special meeting uh special
uh our special system meeting
we will those will not be available
you'll have to
anything you get any any uh
paperwork you take with you but that's
so you will not have the drawers
available but they are
once we get back to regular order uh the
uh nc to sign for security notification
again this is this has to do with the
uh um
with our normal order when uh there will
be a seat closest to the
to the door that goes to the office
uh that seat uh uh will put uh
put a uh a rep is that
to in that person's that rep
will be uh will be
their reps responsibility will be to go
in and call security if we are having a
problem
uh you know we are in the public we are
have a public hearing
and sometimes people and the public get
a little
agitated uh
that that uh you know the uh
this is rare but it has happened it has
not happened to me
but it's happened to other chairs where
uh somebody gets rambunctious
and looks like they they they need to
they we need the presence of of a
uh security person and they or there
will
be there is a a signal that i will give
to that person who's in that chair to
make a phone call
to security
but there are also maybe times that that
person will have to
run out run and get uh running call for
uh you know someone has a heart
problem or some medical issue again
those issues those that's
that's what that chair is about any
questions on that
okay don't see any uh okay
uh fire our
alarm exit because we can can you
you have to uh well i
i think that's kind of self-explanatory
uh the committee itself
those are the ground rules then the
committee itself
uh the committee has as a charge i mean
the committee charges resources right
resources recreation and developments
nine it's
uh item section 30 of our rules
committee on resources recreation and
development
to consider all matters relating to
natural resources
water pollution and control parks and
recreation areas
recreational industries matters
concerning state control on property
development
and such other matters as may be
referred to it
that's what we do that's uh that's our
charge but that
you notice they said all other matters
that may be referred to it
so don't don't be surprised if there
isn't things that we get that
doesn't fall into that i try to get rid
of those bills but sometimes
i can't uh now the uh
partisan balance on on the uh
this on the uh
on the the partisan balance on uh the
committee uh it's just these
constitution requires it the rules
require
a partisan balance generally uh
the uh we have uh we have a
bar that we have a balance of
uh 11 republicans in the in the majority
and
10 democrats that's as that is as close
a
of a partisan balance as you can as you
can get
uh the uh there's
i i have never been on a uh on any
committee that has an equal number
uh usually it's the majority and my
minority but
uh committee seating at the discretion
of the chair
what i will be would normally have done
uh there's a a committee uh
there's a a form that i fill out it's
just stuff it just uh has it it has
a you see here yeah i'm trying to talk
with my hands it's my italian inning
but i try to you you have
a you have a basically the
the cut out of the uh a drawing of the
uh the layout of of the of the room
it has in it where
people will sit i
as chair make
the determination where people sit
i will definitely be uh consulting
representative smith
uh uh and to get to get her
input and help in setting and setting
this up
uh the normally what a
the the way that the front the
it's the chair the desk or the
tables are set up in a u-shaped form of
inverted u the is this this the center
for the uh of the base of the u
is uh then the center of that
table is the chair to
send and so to my right will be
the uh the uh
vice chair and to
uh the vice to his uh right will be the
ranking
uh member okay to my left will be the
clerk
and usually you keep an empty spot there
on the
on the end beside the clerk simply
because
it's good the clerk will have a lot of
the
the paperwork that would normally come
in said
and she keeps the files and things of
that nature
so there's a necessity for additional uh
space oh in by the clerk
then along these two sides there will be
mixture
of folks there will be
the more senior people will
will be toward the front uh
they would hopefully so
we can try to try to put senior people
next to uh
senior people next to uh more
the next to more next to the new people
uh and mix up uh
democrat and republican to get uh
so you can get to know basically know
have help and know and get to know your
people around you
and you believe me
it's good to it's good to do this this
way because
you you get to know somebody that you
know the
in in the in the the world outside you
know
there seems to be a lot of they miss
they
they miss the uh uh the
fact that just because somebody has a an
r or a d
next to their name doesn't it doesn't
make them bad
it's just you know they you're just
different to the they'll have a
different
uh different you know they have a
different idea on something
that's that's it you'll know people and
don't be afraid to ask you have a
question especially
the new folks if you have a question on
a
procedure ask me i don't care if you're
uh i don't care what you're a d or an r
it's
ask representative smith i'm certain she
doesn't
she she doesn't care whether you're a d
or an r we're here to
we are here to guide you along and i
think i can say
speak say that for any of those
those of us who have been here uh
more than one term or or been here at
least a term
in other words they'll help you as best
they can
yeah and we try to do that on the
committee
uh because you'll find that most of the
decisions we make are unanimous
oddly enough and which is which kind of
is surprising because uh
i'm a i'm a hard-nosed republican from
back
back and yet i'm there are five times
that i will
yeah okay that's and so i will very
uh it's it is the yeah it's just the way
things are happen because that's mostly
what do what
what we end up doing uh
b any questions on that
all right uh typical build topics
i think just what i just said on the
part is on the uh
by the char the charge of what the
committee does we have
21 bills so far uh
here's some i'll just give you an idea
of what
one of the just a just a couple of them
you can look them up by the way you can
look up all the bills
uh just uh just go on the
www.gencore.state
dot nh dot u
s that will get you into this the uh
the the state system if anybody who has
done it
do it you can you can just hunt around
in it just go where it says
committee we'll first click on uh
on the house then you click on committee
uh
and you can go to res resources
recreation and development
and you can get a list of all the bills
and then there are ways to you can pull
the bills down but some of the bills
that
just a couple a couple one resid
relative to seasonal platforms on public
waters of the state
wake surfing prime wetlands
uh rail trails uh
[Music]
standards on pop pur uh per and poly
fluoroalkyl substances pfas and drinking
water
and ambulance water uh there
you know and finally one that just
hit me that uh when i was looking these
up i said oh my god
abolishing fluoridation in water so
that's coming back so
that that's that's uh that is the kind
of
bills that we can typical topics
uh any questions on that
uh second committee work
uh judith do you have a question yeah
you're not you're not
can't hear you
well there's a certain value to that
yeah i wasn't quite sure when to ask
this question
so in terms of i think particularly for
those of us who have bills coming up
um or who are trying to arrange for a
testimony on a bill
is there any limit on the amount of
time that somebody will be allowed to
testify
i know i i assume that we're going to
continue with the tradition
of never telling anyone that they can't
testify
but if we're trying to plan for um
for the introduction of a bill
uh has there been any talk about the how
chairs are going to determine how how
much time people will be given will it
be
one person talking for three minutes or
will it be the whole
charter school being allowed to come and
talk
uh what i think as i know
for now it's all it's it is all at the
discretion of the chair
uh if uh if it's something is
coming in that is you know fresh
or or new you know or somebody's the
first
first person testifying uh and
that's your keynote person
then i may allow a little bit i may
allow more
than if it's uh if it's the 20th person
wanting to repeat
everything that that's been said
previous
so what are the things that i will do
and i
i have i i will use the old trick of
reading the people's
i'll be doing a people sell a fill out
well there's gonna be a virtual pink
card
and on that virtual pink card it's going
to be a
length of time they were put down for a
testimony when they tempted
when they speak if it's if it's
due to spaying for three minutes and
that's what's written on there that's
what i will read back to you
i will say judith spang you're speaking
for three minutes correct
and that's well i will do that if i
have a large number of pink cards okay
so there'll be no limit on the
number of people who will be able to
speak say there's an
a local issue and the entire
conservation commission wants to come in
and testify yes 10 of them
uh if it looks like it's dilatory and i
have a lot of people
i may i may have to say uh
i will i will say are you is there
something
is there something you're going to be
telling us that is
different from the previous testimony
if they're if they say yes and they
don't do that
i will say is there something that you
do that is different from the previous
testimony
and then if they if they don't do that
if they ignore me again i will i will
say that this
is dilatory and i will rule them out of
order
i mean i uh i've only got um
i have limited amount of time uh i will
i will be as flexible you know i'm as
flexible as possible on this
uh but if if it looks like
i've got a if you know especially if one
of these things goes into a
uh a long uh
you know a long testimony it could be
you know
it's interfering with other people's
rights now we if there's something that
i know
is going to be a large long testimony we
will try to
put it in we will try to schedule a
large amount of time
i mean yes there's times you get burned
but
you know like for instance i assume
there's going to be a large amount of
time
on testimony for uh
for the for the fluoridation
and i will make it a long they won't be
it won't be a half an hour
so i don't know if i've answered your
question but
yeah that's great that's kind of what i
was expecting and i'm hoping that the
other
to get a good idea from the other chairs
on about how they're going to handle it
i had a
a bill last year where um 15
kids from a charter school came and they
each delivered one sentence
and i'm not sure how that will fly this
year
the other thing and it's kind of related
we have new people who are not familiar
with
some of our issues and i'm wondering if
we could have brown bag
presentations or maybe a presentation
when on one of the days that we are not
in session ourselves and able
to bring people up to speed i know we
have in the past on that
um i know that rick vanderpoll came in
and gave a lecture on uh wetlands
and why they need to be protected and
how to do it
and i think that that's very useful i
don't know whether
um with some of the atv issues whether a
little background
on what has been going on there might be
useful
that you wouldn't necessarily get
testimony okay uh
i'll have to consider what it is on a
case-by-case basis
uh i got there are other questions i got
two other hands up
did i all right uh
okay i see well i see representative
post
and uh i don't know who the other one is
that's
off my screen here uh
it's representative smith oh okay uh
well i gotta call representative post
first then i'll uh
representative post thank you um
i just wanted to know with the um bills
can we post them
on our facebook page um
to reach out to people in our areas in
our towns that might be interested in
them
is that appropriate uh
i don't see any any reason why not
uh representative smith um
yeah first i'd answer uh lisa a
representative post
um you can also just post the link to
the general court website to the bill
you don't have to write the bill itself
the other thing uh
which leads me to this question of uh
usually we are given paper copies of all
of the bills before the committee
have we figured out how we're going to
do that this year
all right what's going to happen uh
as and that's that is that there's an
issue
you know i'm concerned about about that
as well what because what
the as i know it's
right now we will be getting
a packet if the if
if you're in the if you are attending
in person i was told we will be getting
the uh a packet that will have the bills
in
that will be had that will have the
testimony
that is uh or any uh any printed
uh any uh information that is supplied
to the committee uh will be uh
will be put together by
the uh the committee services
and we will be greeted with a packet
of information uh
and this stuff that we would normally
get as handouts
uh will be asked will have to come in uh
and set be sent to the
uh committee services prior
there have so people will have to sign
up
and get their stuff in to the
uh to committee services to in order to
be handed out
to us for hard copies uh the
i would i'm going to assume that all of
that information that comes in
will also be on the
uh on the wire or on you know online
for so though to for those who do not
attend in person uh
the as far as copies of all the bills
i'll find out if we i can find out if we
can get them all mailed
at once to us
yeah i think that let me mark that down
as something to do
yeah mail all copies yeah and also my
understanding
is that all of the testimony will be
done virtually
yes all of the testimony will be done
virtually
none of the uh
there will be no place for someone to
come in
and sit down to present their bill even
if they're on another committee that is
meeting
and start in the building they can't
come in
uh and because you you don't want
any because people won't want to
want to come in just to you know just to
make their presentation hand stuff out
well if you allow that for one you gotta
allow that for all
so you can't do it so that's they said
no
so that's um
that's uh how's getting uh getting the
information
okay i have another question yeah is um
do we know yet uh
the status of the air exchangers for the
clean air
uh we there's there
there's going to be an attempt at using
a
uh doing a
one committee is going to be they i
they've
said that one committee will be will be
trying a trial run
uh uh next
this coming week that may be
that uh that to me means that
at least there are some of the portables
available
um and uh i have myself
once i find out what one that is i will
probably be more looking in
on it to see how they they the problems
they run into
i mean uh uh the
uh i've hopefully uh they say i think
rep
they've may that meeting might still be
going on hopefully representative gunski
who's
who's there uh will be able to come back
and
you know fill us in what's happening uh
and he might have more of an update on
that if not uh
we'll i'll get an update out because uh
uh
i he will i'll ask him to
you know write something out and say and
get it to everyone
in at any rate if he's if he's not in by
that time
by the by the end of this meeting uh the
uh uh the
yeah i mean let's see i thought i had
something else
yeah i missed uh any other questions on
that uh
oh yeah first of all um the
the just to get to show you how
difficult some of these is
some of the ques some of this is
used under normal circumstances people
would come in
they'd have their their uh testimony
uh written out they'd they'd hand it out
to
to the to the representatives they would
have a
they would fill out what they call a
pink card and the pink card would
have on who they are who they what they
represent and how long they want to
speak and then what side they're
for or against and
something as simple as a they're filling
out that card
uh having to do it do it all
virtually is now a
major production they have to fill out
the card
prior to it to the hearing get it in it
has to get
sent get brought to the chair has to be
copied
uh a chair has to sort it out so it
suddenly becomes
a something that was a two minute job
suddenly becomes a half-hour job so it's
that kind of
issue that we're we're facing uh
anything else did i answer your
questions
or best as i can there are still some
questions that i have but
you know as i try to work through it but
uh
yeah anything else representative smith
mr channel uh yes representative
harp thank you um
on the days of the hearing are you going
to set specific
times or i think we passed a rule that
you could list them all for the same
time and we just take them concurrently
after we finish one
what is your intent on that i would
rather not do that
uh that's that's the senate way and it's
what kind of
protects them
if you ever go to the senate they you
they they had a ten up everything's at
ten a ten o'clock ten oh one ten oh two
twenty
and they have all of the bills listed
and you your people can be wasting a lot
of time waiting
for their their turn i would rather not
do it i think
what they all what they are allowing to
do
is if you have bills of the same
type which have the same
uh the the same cast of characters
testifying suppose it's a
uh ohrv bills oh set of
bills like that and then we had several
that were all
very similar you can
take those all at once
you don't have to keep having the same
you don't have to keep having the
everybody testify on the same bill
on the time you excuse me you could have
everybody to that
you can take the testimony from one bill
and use it
on the other so if you if you uh if you
gather them together
and hopefully that will save some time
uh
did i answer your question okay
uh the other okay i don't want this uh
i'm gonna let's see just gonna quickly
second committee work for those who are
new
they will get we will get bills that
have to be out for
a that have to go for to a second
committee
so those have to get done first
uh because we have a limit we'll have
basically half the time
to get it get them taken care of what's
usually
annoying and unfortunate is that
they are usually bills that have money
involved
and they're usually fairly complicated
so it makes
it makes life difficult so
uh i don't know if i can answer any
questions on that but
uh that's that's that's just a fact of
life
um the uh subcommittees
sometimes the bill has uh is we like we
may have
some bill has issues we may take uh
we may we may get a set up a group
of uh of reps
uh committee members to be part uh to go
offline
and see what they can if they can
improve it or hash do some
you know hash out what it is that is
wrong with the bill either
either come back with a recommendation
and come back with a recommendation to
committee whether it's
ought to pass out to pass with an
amendment or
itl which is in the expedient to
legislate it's a
it it allows a subcommittee
is as some is put together by
is allowed by the chair
if the chair wants it it is highly
discouraged
in this time we just haven't got the
time
to do to do a lot of that uh
it's it may what you may see
uh is instead of putting a subcommittee
on it we may retain a bill that is as
retaining as well is when we in the
committee vote to keep it
and not not getting pass it to the floor
you have to get in
and spend some later time working on it
uh it means again kicking the can down
the road
but if we feel that the bill deserves
some
deserves at least some uh additional
work
and we really don't feel we have the
time to do it rather than kill it
maybe we just you know we we
move it down you may see a lot more
retained bills
because during this this time
them those um uh there's
things about all right there's things
about bill files and things like that
but that's
about it uh we'll
talk about the any clerk any
questions on that where we're going uh
i'm uh i'm going to talk a little about
the public hearings and the executive
session public hearings
no you're going to have witnesses you
don't debate the witnesses you know
that's not what they're here for you're
there
you're to ask them questions the
questions come through the chair
that they they are not
they should not be
uh speeches if there's a
if there's you know they uh they should
be quiet all the questions come through
the chair in other words
you you basically raise your hand
i reckon i recognize you for uh
and you said for a question i said okay
for a question
you get a question you don't ask a
second question you say
you have you turn to the chair and say
uh
i've not you know for a follow-up you
know i'll say
you know for a follow-up do uh
if the one thing that
is that is done and i and it's
it is not a very good thing
and you uh is you will
somebody will will start making a speech
and then we'll say would you believe
well that is not a question
that is a that is a speech
put in the form of a question and
it's not it's really not something that
that should
that you really should do uh
did i any questions on that
no okay uh other than
that okay uh uh
okay when the sponsor is a member of the
committee
all right the sponsor can
fosux delivers the bill or introduces
the bill
and speaks on the bill through the
uh in normally
in the uh in the in the uh
uh the on the testimony table there's a
normally a testimony table uh because
there will be no testimony table
i will waive that requirement
and you'll make your testimony that's
that's me they may they make they may
overrule me on that
but i i figure it's if you're there
you will make your testimony view
however
if ces uh test
anyone who is a sponsor of a bill
they can take their testimony and the
the
the the co-sponsors
also can their testimony but they cannot
ask questions of any of the
uh of the of others that are that are
testifying
they just sit there uh
and that's that's uh how i
uh how that how that goes any questions
on that
okay now i see one thing in here that
says no action on
bill the same day as hearing uh
that is no
i don't uh i think that might be
uh overruled uh eventually because
uh there is a go there is going to be
apply uh put on every notice
that uh there could be an executive
session
at any time uh during
during the day that's gonna it has been
done before i personally
don't like it i will not necessarily i
will not do it
except in the decisions system situation
i will uh i will
there if a bill appears to be
uh something that everyone seems to
agree on
at some point i may uh uh i may consult
uh or with uh
uh or i i will make i may just bring up
a question i could say i will i will
just
uh the that
uh if if it appears to me that where the
things are going to be
we could that we
have time to do that we have bills that
could be taken care of
without having a uh
a notified executive session because
there is a notification
already that would cover having a media
here immediate executive session we
we could we we could do that but i would
if there's appears to be uh
any uh any issues involved i would
simply
uh adjourn that executive session
without a finding
and postpone the executive session
to a uh a a later date with a
with a hearing uh hearing with a
notified executive session
so there is a possibility of being able
to get
to get your process to process
bills quickly if we have
a to with which we have a
appears to be a closely unanimous
decision
on it to just so we don't have to keep
plowing the same earth
um yeah any uh
any other anybody any questions no
uh executive session first of all
yeah there's no if you're in the
executive session
there is no public input
unless the chair allows it uh
usually that is only allowed
for a if there is a question on
something
representative has a question uh
you know if it's if it's a is a
legitimate question
yeah uh i will allow i will allow that
if uh uh yeah
but uh somebody waving their arms
uh in the audience or say hey i want to
be uh you know i got something to say
no you had your chance to say it at the
uh uh yeah at the hearing
um there will be amendments and the
amendments are prepared by ols
and and will be supplied to
committee members but i don't think
we'll just i won't even worry about
i won't worry about that but in a normal
situation in the
ring executive session first of all
there will be before
executive sessions at some point at
least on
the republican side and i'm assuming on
the democrat side
there will be caucuses and you have to
you should caucus
simply to get find out
where where where the where where
everybody is on the
on the bills once you will have some of
the caucuses i think will
long as we have i i would rather the if
you have caucuses
that they're done outside of the
the time that we have to take care of
bills
in other words do it do it the day ahead
of time
you know you can do it uh yeah you can
do it at night
do it do it on the and caucuses are not
you don't have to worry about uh
right to work right to no law um
the roll call which was under normally
what the the clerk
will happen is when everybody is
finished and all of the
bill all of the the motions have been
made
and and we're ready to vote
the uh i will i'll i will
declare will ask the clerk to please
call the role
but the clerk the first person to vote
will be the vice chair of the majority
you know the vice chair will be
representative gunski
he uh then the clerk will go down
the list of republicans except for the
chair
then the the the when
the next after all the law the
republicans have voted
the the ranking democrat will vote
representative smith
and then the chair will continue calling
the role
and then the last person to vote will be
the chair
and and the clerk will
read the uh will read the uh
uh the the the state of the vote
the state of the ballot uh then though
if you
people have to write committee reports
using a committee report is or committee
for it we
i still call them blurbs i'm sorry uh
but
uh somebody decided to call a book
committee reports uh we will uh
the the they'll be the person making
the motion
will be the one who will write
the committee report where i write the
blurb
the if there is a re minority report
says someone can
say i will write about a minority report
i will say is there a minority report
and that will if then
that you you would write that minority
report
the reports have to be submitted to the
chair i will
have to review them i review them
for uh for
veracity well that
let's say one of course i will try try
to
do it as easy as much as freedom of
speech allows
uh you know you you have to
there's specific requirements on
what a a uh
blurb is uh uh how what's what you put
in it
uh you should if you if there's an
amendment to the bill you say what the
amendment does
uh you put down what are the facts about
the of the bill
and they should be facts uh they should
not be personal
you should be uh uh you know yeah
so and so did this well now okay
you have to because what'll happen is
the
if if there's a problem with the with
the blurb but it gets by me
then and it might very well this has
happened before
is that uh it's
it's uh it gets looked at by the by the
uh by these uh clerk
um you know the you know paul paul smith
the clerk of the house
he reads it because it has to go into
the uh
into the into the the the blue sheets
then
this the uh into the uh
calendar and also
uh the speaker reads him
because it's it's a fact in effect his
calendar
and then i go i would get a call so
uh the
uh look at some of the the uh
see if you can look at
look at some previous uh
blurbs in some other calendars there
will be
you you might get some um if you see
find one of
maybe if uh representative smith will uh
give you some of hers she writes a very
good blurb
so it'll tell you it'll it you can get
an idea what uh what's great what's
necessary
uh uh and
also by the way when you write the blurb
be prepared to be the person to defend
it
and we will work on that we're
far away from that any questions
you know i'd like to see people about
ready to hit their heads about ready to
hit the desk
uh committee staff
uh committee researcher
uh brad
hi everyone i'm uh brad greenland um
so um the becoming researcher
um in house community services is um
nonpartisan
and we provide any research needs for
the committee
about about the legislation in front of
them
all research requests do need to go
through the chair
and then material will relay that
information to us
we also um look over the um committee
reports as well
for any grammatical errors um
and make sure they're good to go before
they're sent off
and we also um like i said earlier we're
nonpartisan
and um so any partisan research you'd
like done you would have to go
through um the different partisan
offices
and that's pretty much the role in a
nutshell um
i'm not sure if anyone has any questions
for that for me but
uh just also you uh
uh the community researcher usually
part of his his function uh is to supply
us with
uh uh we without with
with copies of the law uh
that we're in the area where work we're
working
there may be an issue that is
that i may ask the committee researcher
to get involved with for the for the
benefit of the committee
uh yeah that there's there's uh
he has to actually uh you know i may say
what would do you have any information
can you find me any information on
uh that uh on prior bills and things of
that nature
so uh
the you have to that's his time is
limited
because he has these committee
researchers
uh have to service several committees
so it has you have to go through the
chair
to be able to uh access
his help um elaborate
um we also um so the research we provide
is like representative renzo said um
any bill histories on any previous
legislation or if that bill had come up
before
we do 50 state surveys um to see what
other states are doing
and um those are the two
major ones that we that we do and any
other
um if you have any questions about like
a particular topic or something we can
research that for you as well
thank you brad thank you now also there
is committee assistance
committee assistant says that's um
heather goalie
you see
she will she will set us up with stuff
she
takes she sets the room up
how much she's going to be doing
relative to
setting up the room and things and with
our name
tags by the way you do get a name tag
it's a not a name tag
a name plate uh you'll start off if
you're
a new person with uh just on paper
but uh you eventually get a wooden one
uh
with a with the plastic uh
name and then your name on it uh
that she sets that up she sets up the
she sets up the room
for us and then she also is the person
that uh the clerk uh
deals with and she also
sends out the notices for the meeting
member resources administrative support
fourth floor
you go up to the fourth floor you get
supplies you get
clerical support you get copying done up
there
that's on the fourth floor uh
the the statutes uh the laws are in the
committee room
statutes are also available again
on the uh on the uh the
website uh the house website
and the uh the gen court dot state dot
nh dot u s status
statutes are in there on that and
available there
computers and phones uh in the state
house
uh they're uh
the lob they're as
the fourth floor again you have a
computer room and you have phones
wireless computer access you have that
already
uh that's available in the on the campus
um
any uh you know any issues on rules
you know call paul smith uh
that's about if uh other things
uh there's a lot of things about what
this
the chair has to do but i think that's i
think i've already wiped you out
already i see people's heads hitting the
i see people are going when is he going
to finish well i'm finished
uh so is it
equal yeah any questions all right uh i
have a question
yes uh you mentioned the copy machine up
on the fourth floor
is going to be available for us if we go
i i uh they are available in the normal
circumstances i will find out if they
are available
uh i will find out if they are
available during the pandemic okay
okay let me i got the machine okay yep
uh those are these it's all things i'll
be sending out
uh as soon as i'm finished here
any other questions anybody has
you know uh speak now or forever
ever hold your peace uh jesus chuck
you're not saying anything
did i did i tire you out i've been
sleeping
candy so i i think it is a good time to
do that
i know i know i know i did i was
sleeping too
i noticed anything else i think you did
a good job as far as uh
you know particularly for the new
members those of us who are returning
um it's pretty much the same as usual
except for we're doing it virtually
right now but when we
back to the rooms uh you know hopefully
we'll get to be able to see people face
to face so yeah
this this is tough right this this is uh
i'm i'm kind of sad for the uh for the
new folks because
uh you're you you your
your first year is you know it's not
it's not what it normally is you're
missing the pageantry a bit
you're missing the there's a there's a
whole flavor
to it well just just the camaraderie
particularly you know i i
mean bob and mike michael last session
and you know put up with those two guys
was almost almost as difficult as
dealing with you andy but
no nobody's as bad as me oh that's
that's that's true
and that's true but luckily i had bob
and mike on both sides of me to protect
me from
you know from you so no they were glad
you were there because you were taking
the hits
but it but at
any rate uh all the new folks uh
this isn't normally the way it is and
one of the things that it just this is
just you know end with
uh the my first time i walked up
the stair up i walked up to toward the
the state house i was a newbie never
served
day one and i looked up and the building
looked back
and said don't screw it up and and that
that was kind of got to me i mean it was
just that you were
you were walking into a historic place
and now you were part of history and i i
i'm sad that you just don't don't we
haven't really had a chance to
experience it yet
but you will uh and
it's it's a it's it is an experience and
you'll
you'll gain friends and uh on both sides
of the aisle you'll gain enemies on both
sides of the aisle too
but it's part of you know it's it's part
of the system and it's
and we have the best democracy in the
whole country
because you got 400 people and you
you can't corrupt 400 people unless it's
the congress
so you know the uh but
it's all it's it's they say it's like
like herding cats to a car wash but
this is this is democracy and i think
you'll you'll you'll like it
you know so at any rate uh
any other anybody who has anything more
to say anybody have uh
yeah yeah that being that
we uh i will adjourn the meeting i will
not ask for a vote because i'm just by
doing it by
ex it is just simply adjourned
bye see you later thank you